if you were over the age of 13 and you
still use Snapchat I just want you to
know that you're a little especially if
you're still keeping snap streaks if you
make it a point of your day to keep this
minuscule number look at his brain just
Computing what to what to hate let's see
what who is this for what 14 year olds
like who's the target audience for this
like literally oh dude I'm 14 now we're
going you have
like what
what was that point like what was that
point you just I just can't with this
guy because he all he does is find stuff
to hate like he watches a video and he's
like what can I hate on in this video
that's that's his brain like a lot of
people they watch a video and they try
to like think about it or find some
positivity well most people don't think
actually all right looked at some of the
comments on his video and everybody on
there is just a hater it's just the way
their whole mind works is how can I say
something mean it's kind of sad crazy
man nothing better to do in your life
look at that as a sign that you need to
wake up and escape this no like for real
this is like like I've never I mean I'm
I'm 31. so for me this is so far outside
of my hold on a second scope of real
quick Mr Producer he's 31 is that is
that a Snapchat yes so he's got his
Snapchat handle yet he acknowledges that
any messages for Snapchat is are going
who's this even for 14 year olds well
this is even four like 14 year olds I
have like I know 20 people in their
early 20s that still use Snapchat and
consistently into streaks like bro it's
not just 14 year olds that use Snapchat
because we grew up with Snapchat like my
age like early 20s and now it's like
people still ask for snaps when they go
up to girls and I think that's so
childish I would never ask for a girl's
Snapchat no one's ever asked me for my
snap
yeah I'll keep it that way you stay home
you stay home what what's what's a
Snapchat
streak like what are you talking about
you don't know you got your snap handle
on your video kid okay it's like the
Snapchat streak like what this is hard
right because don't stoop and and make
fun of them like that okay but he he
makes up points at least that's how he
sounds all right all right let's go
don't get mad but I agree with that oh I
agree with him too I agree with him I
agree with him I agree with him too I
just know for a fact that he had just
deleted Snapchat I feel like a week
before 100 or he actively has streaks
and the way that he first comes in with
like if you still have Snapchat like I
have a Snapchat underneath me right here
and I have Snapchat and streaks I don't
have streets yes I know what streaks are
no I have a couple girls that I'm
talking to my generation streaks is when
you didn't wipe your butt right after
you pooped and you got streaks in your
underwear no I'll check Snapchat once in
a while because there's there's people
that only have my contact there so I'll
download it check it and then just
delete it but I don't want it on my
phone all the time I think a lot of
people could use that advice I don't
know why I'm the why I'm the devil here
yeah it's not about it it's good advice
everybody needs to have fewer things on
their phone and spend more time in the
real world the irony that's not even an
account any longer like there's not even
a real account it I just don't know how
to take it off my my I don't know how to
delete it from this thing oh so I just
is just there I have always known
himself almost as if he heard me okay
successful since before I was making any
money
wait what is he talking about back then
in the brogie days like I'm 16 now but
back when I was 14 dude I was a broke
and then I got a job at the Dairy Queen
dude and man am I Caked Up Now even back
in my broken days when I was still
working at a bar the bartenders really
like walk reacting to this dude reacting
to them reacting to me like what the
[__] well let's go let's go because they
said some interesting things we did
rookie yes that sounds derogative
that sounds really derogatory doesn't it
dude
you have to be careful how you use it
because I think it can it can come off
as really mean because a lot of people
are doing the best they can and they're
working jobs and just because they're
working jobs nothing gets done without
workers
for us they're not broken I would never
call them brokies they're hard workers
and it's and it's a shitty everybody
can't have their own business without
anybody working for them yeah definitely
I mean if you want to grow your business
everyone needs the brokeys and their
businesses stop it I'll smack you he's
they're right they're right it's mean
the bartenders were talking to me and
making plans about my yacht in Miami for
when I'm older and Rich if you don't
even display that confidence and believe
in yourself that you're gonna make it
one day how do you ever expect to
achieve your goals yes you need to take
all the proper steps to achieve
financial report like having goals and
like wanting stuff for your life like
what is he talking about like you also
need a truth yeah bro he's caked up he's
got the RGB lights that he got off of a
tick tock ad he's wearing like what are
those are those in hyzers I don't even
know why does he look so wet like he
just looks so because you're Italian
is Hassan a racist is he calling me a
grease ball
that's crazy man I thought you were like
woke up my little meatball wow yeah I'd
say it's like I don't know what's
happening it's so that's so moist that's
why this is why I shaved my head this is
such pettiness Hassan said I had greasy
hair so I was like oh I just got a
Gorgeous Hair listen this is this is
like Beyond Petty sitting and making fun
of somebody's greasy skin I mean that's
just how he said he's 31 years old and
he's making fun of how people look like
what are you doing Hassan pull yourself
together it's like me when I first start
buyer dynamic 770s is that what you're
saying I don't know what this is really
believe it in yourself and know that
you're going to make it there one day
most absurd thing about this to me is
that everything that he's saying is
completely valid yeah he's not the one
that should be telling you yeah anyways
only takes 2i there's a lot of people
that look at me and they can relate me
for a lot of these messages you don't
always just want to look at a 34 year
old dude that's already done everything
sometimes it's nice to see someone in
similar shoes as you yes that's done
yeah you're not you're not a rich kid
you're born with a silver spoon in your
mouth I mean we did all right but it was
you didn't live in a big old mansion
just it just upsets me like these people
are they're so negative and it's like
this is what's rewarded with brand deals
and stuff like it's I I go to Brands you
know you go to store posting Boutique
let's controversial figures AdSense is
garbage and it's like these are the guys
that get all the good brand deals the
ones that just talk nonsense and push
negative negativity all the time and I'm
just trying to help people it's crazy to
me like I'm not YouTube isn't even all
for money like it's it's wild it really
doesn't make as much as like YouTube
doesn't like I mean it does well it does
well but it's not no one's guessing my
point is like the views that I'm getting
in any other Niche if it wasn't red
pilled it would make 10 times more yes
it would make 10 times more but then
we'd have to sell our souls yeah it's
crazy not happening two weeks to cure
depression I don't want to hear anything
to push the depression narrative and
push negativity like they're
incentivized to and we're punished for
pushing this but how is pay picking on
people's appearances incentivized but I
say something about a crazy like when we
were watching the what is a woman
footage and and there was the wolf lady
man whatever it was the human who
thought who was transgender and thought
it was also a wolf trans species and you
know I say something negative about that
and I'm an [__] I'm not hiring any
[__] animals at my company I'm sorry
but these guys can make fun of my our
Italian greasy skin and it's okay huh
but but Hassan talked about Tate didn't
he didn't he talk to Tate yeah just
curious okay
you don't need pills you don't need
therapy I've never been to a doctor in
my life yeah I was thinking about this
earlier too and like there's so many
different things that people set like
mental blocks on themselves even with
like like creative what is it called
when when you're like a writer and you
hit like a creative block I just like
don't believe in that stuff like I'm
just not there's so many different
ideologies that have been put in our
brain that all it does is set limits on
you like why would I ever believe that I
can get writer's block like I can just
do something else I can walk away I can
sit there and just close my eyes and
think like my brain maybe I'm just
different but like when I'm driving my
brain is going crazy like I'm coming up
with so many different thoughts I feel
like I could write a book for each like
two-hour car drive that I run because my
brain goes on so many different tangents
like it's insane right but that's that's
the time to do it so I'll tell you I'm a
writer writer's block is real and what I
do is yeah I just leave so it's not real
you just like no I can I overcome it it
is real where you just kind of you stop
job you're so
um writing say a story and I'll just
stop and I I just feel like I I don't
know I can't get the next part of it out
so I'll just go I'll go for a drive I'll
go to the gym I'll do whatever I'll live
my life and then all of a sudden boom it
comes and then it pours out again yeah
it's it's it's more of it but people
always Block it's uh waste of years of
their life like there's artists and
musicians that your job is to make music
and you'll like spend years to do
something like years you need that much
time what do you mean like you you write
the lyrics You film you you record the
song you fix it up like come on like
these people like in so many different
aspects it just takes so long a lot of
that is fear of putting it out there in
perfect no I know but I'm just saying
that as like as one example like there's
so many different things and even the
writer's block thing like there's so
many there's so many different mental
caps that people set on themselves all
the time that I'm just trying to trying
to get rid of I don't know that they put
them there it's that when they do get
there they use them as an excuse for not
being productive and not moving forward
and the speed thing is something that
you know I'm glad you picked up on but
because it is the way to go you know
another thing Alex come here so like the
other day we were filming a video with
fat G and Alex was tired and he kept
like yawning and [__] you know they
start editor Alex he's staying with us
right now
well he kept yawning and [__] while we
were filming and I told him I was like
yo cut that [__] out right now because
like you're gonna make everyone else
more tired yeah if you don't stop that
and he's like I'm tired or like I feel
brain dead like bro yeah we all got
shellacked last night kid suck it up you
put that energy out there and it infects
everyone else so even like by the end of
the trip me and Alex we stopped bitching
about that stuff like he was like just
keep it inside I'm going just yeah
bitching about things and all
complaining makes everything worse for
yourself and everything around you
that's the truth does nothing does
nothing it does nothing he's Sunny fast
and Mom that's wait he's with his mom oh
my God there's literally nothing more
Alpha than having a tick tock account
not only dedicated to you being a sigma
grind set guy but like you're so young
that you need to have your mom with you
as your supervisor
oh my God this is the most Italian coded
[__] I've ever seen what the what does
that even mean oh thank God we're expl
Italian coded I don't even know it means
it's delicious it's wearing this dude
okay okay I can't we gotta watch this
guy what
this guy literally reacts to [__] with
his mom here for your safety when a man
cat calls you 100
all the time now I'm not excusing it why
is catcon such a big deal I think cat
calling is such a big deal because I'm
not out here dressed like this you can
give a little oh my hand of the outfit
this is not for others view this is for
me you dress like that and you do your
hair and you put on all that makeup when
you're home alone okay pumpkin we buy
that wait what spooky quiet scary
atmosphere piano songs Skittle girl
sound that's not even over this video
I don't have Tech talk yeah you don't we
don't have neither of us have tick tocks
so that's funny that's a copycat account
but okay also isn't it ironic that she's
like saying oh you dress up in your own
house just to sit like that
bro you're dressed up in your own house
like you're quite literally in your own
house
and you're dressed up yeah inside that
was this that might have been one of the
dumbest points I've ever seen I don't
know I mean you're getting on camera bro
like what what were you trying to prove
I put on my Italian coding oh sun and
femcell mother I love that oh you you
got all the other tick tockers in the
video too okay this guy this is gonna be
a deeper dive than this video what his
mom isn't a fan sadly carry a bunch of
personal biases and when we analyze
situations we do not have enough scope
to grab wait they reacted to me oh the
mom reacted to me the entirety of the
situation not comprehend it with our
human brains you can drive you're
driving your truth from an internet
study that's fine you can derive them in
and study on a bunch of different things
that's honestly another thing is that
how how can you really trust anything
you see on the internet when everything
that's portrayed to you is there's a
reason it's being portrayed to you that
way that's what I said you know so funny
watching myself from back then it wasn't
even that long ago it was only about
eight months ago and you look so
different you're right at that age where
you're just changing a lot bro I'm bald
like what the [__] oh but your face is
changing you're growing and changing
yeah
second reasoning for the person putting
that out like a baby it's crazy you do
that he says there's you know so much
more around our understanding than we
can understand yet he won't acknowledge
that he can't understand that Tate's
experience is valid I got [__] owned
Mama Bear owned me dude in cell son or
femsol Mom how is this any different
than what what is incel that's like
you're just like a little I don't even
know like all right let's look at the
meaning of this he like he opens up his
little everyone says that like this
little his little insult dictionary
before to practice them before a member
of an online community of young men who
consider themselves unable to attract
women sexually typically associated with
the views that are hostile towards women
oh so we you hate women and I'm I don't
pull bro
only and I hate women no and it's just
it was funny I don't like stupid people
the girls still like my hair they
thought it looked good that's because
they haven't seen the real thing what
are you talking about you have beautiful
thick black wavy hair I hope it grows
back the same and you didn't screw it up
my head's super sunburned right now so I
don't know maybe I'm toast like people
say we're like uh actually how about my
own personal experiences do you hate to
see it dude sometimes mom speaks facts
on lazanabi he's fast shaming good he's
a good thing right I think that when
people say to me you put on a bit of
Timber mate it makes me go back and try
and lose a bit of Timber eat a bit less
drink a bit less get all my pellets on
by off we go right I I need to have
people look at me going Hey Big Boy lose
a bit wait I don't oh let's see his
let's see his point get it like it's not
like Piers is like in good shape you
know what I mean because whenever we
mention it on air as a joke you complain
no no that's it I do that to you because
you're the great virtue signaling we
can't say anything negative about
anybody's body image everyone's perfect
I don't agree reaction to a reaction to
reaction to reaction
yeah well it didn't take so what are you
talking about maybe you should learn
from your own personal experience about
how Pat shimmy didn't work to be fair
though to be fair to peers like I don't
even know how you could fix peers
because like he's shaped like oh
basically everyone I know that was fat
and lost weight said fat shaming was a
good thing like basically all of them
because if you're just told if you're if
you're super fat and all you are is told
that it's super okay and then if the
girls don't want you it's on them it's
not it's not because you're a fat [__]
yeah I just can't stand a fat shaming
[__] shaming this and that we need some
shame okay
you should be ashamed of yourself if
you're not taking care of yourself and
you're doing things that are detrimental
to you and there's nothing wrong with
that I have shame I get ashamed of
myself when I don't behave the way I
want to to the standards I know I could
be acting so what what
now we're shaming people for shaming
people it's just all so stupid so yeah
and I don't think being mean to people
and calling them names like remember
like when you're a little Lambo fatty
fatty two by four I can't fit through
the kitchen door that's what we used to
say to fat kids when we were little it
was mean yeah I mean when people call me
skinny I'm not like
you know I'm like yeah you know I'm
trying to put on some weight oh my god
when I was little I got I was so skinny
I looked like people made fun of me all
the time and then but that doesn't count
it doesn't count so yeah oh that's
another one body shaming so yeah just
you know what everybody needs to grow a
pair and we're at we were at that dinner
with Alex there's a group of feminists
that we were having an argument with and
one of them was like you know like not
to be rude but like you're not the
biggest guy I was like yeah you know
like I'm working on it or something like
that and she was like you know like I
could beat you up and I was like you
genuinely think you could beat me up
like she was like she took a six foot
girl I'm six one and she's like a D1
volleyball player and she's like yeah I
could beat you up I was like you have no
you are you live in a clown world like
if I wanted to kill you right now I
could literally kill you it's insane
though like these feminists they they
live in such a fake reality where they
have no respect for men or anyone around
them she felt confident and comfortable
to say that because the reality is women
can get away with children and I can't
and and know and know that you know
nothing really is going to happen to
them exactly God forbid a man never took
her up on that no that it's it's it's
honestly a scary reality because then
she might go and start hitting hitting
men thinking she's equal because she
plays women's volleyball like yeah it's
a great sport but like come on you're
not gonna go beating up men like I've
noticed a big thing in like these are
like these more traditional girls
they're taught to have respect to men
because men are the ones that get a lot
of this [__] done they're physically
stronger so like maybe I'm not
explaining this super well even when I'm
like to everybody though no yes but like
with guys so like if there's a guy in a
friend group that is like that can beat
up the other guys and the other ones
can't his word literally means more
because like these other guys can't talk
they can only talk so much [__] to him
there's only so much that can be said
against his opinion because at the end
of the day he's the one that can beat
you up and I know this sounds crazy it's
not even just in friend groups but like
in regular altercations like all the
time in the street like if you can beat
somebody up and someone says some some
funny [__] or you're with the girl they
say something to her if you can beat
that guy up he would not only you not
only wouldn't have said that initially
but now you can come back and say stuff
to him but if you know he could beat
your ass then you're just gonna you're
gonna you're gonna run away and you're
gonna be the submissive one in that
altercation so it's similar with women
because men 99 of men are stronger than
like basically you know most women like
basically all women yeah yeah absolutely
you know they you know they dressed up
together you know they dressed up he was
like Mommy I'm gonna wear my full sin
outfit mommy wait he did a 24 minute
video mom reacts the entertain exposed
has he said any like valid points to
something that we said has he countered
any points or has he just trashed my
hair and no he just told us that we're
delicious do we match shirts I'm glad
you like the shirts throughout the match
today don't interrupt me instead no you
are absolutely a typical sjw looking
person bro okay I mean you fix I mean
you I wouldn't be talking about looks
okay I'm just saying mommy I would not
be talking about looks if I were you
stop I'm not going to say it I'm not
gonna say it I'm not going to say it I'm
not going to say it but you're like 60
years old you're saying sjw you should
not know these terms man the internet
broke people so hard so wait a minute so
am I too old to learn new things now
hold up I'm too old to know what's going
on Hassan is that what you're saying all
right he's 31. give wait five minutes
you're gonna be 60 Hassan you're gonna
be in shock at how fast it goes just you
don't even look close to 16. I know he's
he's just being hyper but even still and
then they make fun of your eye and it's
like you you pumped out one of the
greatest human beings known to man and
in that process yeah one of your eyes
got messed up big deal yeah I actually
woke was paralyzed yeah Bell's Palsy um
yeah Hassan if you want to make fun of
my face that's fine but I um I woke up
after my childbirth was traumatic and I
woke up with Bell's Palsy which is uh a
paralysis of the facial nerve so the
right side of my face was completely
paralyzed I couldn't even blink and then
85 percent of people have a full
recovery in 15 percent and I'm one of
the 15. so it's almost like
um it's similar to symptoms of stroke
victims you know what's funny though
like I never noticed you had that until
people pointed it out I could have gone
my whole life without knowing that you
had it and I just wouldn't have known
yeah you were just used to my face it's
weird how that works like I'm just so
used to this face here yeah that I would
have never known and people look at you
instantly and sometimes see it I'm like
that's crazy like I don't see it at all
maybe yeah people that are familiar with
the with the disease they are or their
medical professionals they I mean they
know it instantly and then once in a
while somebody will be like oh my god I
didn't even notice and it depends it's
good days and bad days but yeah I'm
partially paralyzed way to go kids
you're sweet he's racist to Italians
what is it called he didn't say it
unless unless it's coming up I don't
know what is it called when you're um
when you're racist to handicapped people
uh ableist I think ableist yeah yeah
I've never even heard of them until a
week ago but he's some super liberal
dude not even liberal I am not a liberal
what the so I mean there's a picture of
Obama behind him I kind of caught that
liberal Vibe right away okay let's see
oh good we'll just how do you not catch
the Liberals I mean this is a classic
this is like what popped Jordan Peterson
dude I love that you know they're not
even looking at new [__] they're like
going back to the old the old classics
bro ha this is so old half of you must
became right wing after watching this
[__] or were right-wing and became more
right-wing after watching this video uh
way back in the way back in the good old
days you know what I mean
this guy is young enough to still have
his prom picture up and he's and he's
talking like he's a wizard old man I
mean come on to be offended you're right
to not be offended there's no such thing
as a right to not be offended what what
is what is this new [__] where no one
can get offended what is this new [__]
Bro you are the new [__] okay why is
this half cooked fetus talking about the
right not to be offended like he's a
Facebook dad dude
why bro you are offended I didn't let my
son grow up to be a wussy who was crying
over every little thing in his life and
he I'd never let him be complained too
much or let him be offended by
everything and so yeah he understands
that people get offended and they move
on and you want to insult him for that
for having some emotional intelligence
I'm not the one that's offended it's
just he's no he's saying where do you
get off saying those things I taught him
those things Hassan it's that simple
other parents teach their kids to be
offended and to talk to their therapist
about every little thing I was gonna
shake on that listen to your emotions
act on your emotions how do you feel
what do you feel like doing does it
matter like you're a boomer
who is a divorced dad spending all of
his goddamn time on Facebook uh Facebook
meme Pages like uh divorce dad pipeline
divorce dad he's implying that because
they're young you shouldn't think this
way that you shouldn't have a strong
Constitution that's what he's implying
it's just weird and that's just a weird
thing because quite frankly I think it's
fantastic that you're not woke and that
you're not a complete emotional wreck
over everything you feel things but
you're not complaining and whining and
crying and you never tried to be a
victim when things go wrong for you
whenever anything went wrong I was like
oh that's your fault deal with it
something goes wrong in my life I'm like
wow I screwed that up and carry on
that's it
so soft he has got anything done because
they're they're coddled since they're
little to not to to not get offended
money yeah I'm sure this guy living in a
Florida mcmansion who definitely is most
likely still suckling on his mommy's TVs
why would you say that that's all right
so that's not only that is that
disgusting but everything he said has
literally just been an assumption I will
never live nor have I ever lived in a
mcmansion and do not insult me with that
basic [__] [__] like this guy's been
breastfed until he was 14 and he's 15
now and he's acting brand new you know
what I mean that's funny for bulldoze
their parents to do everything for them
these people are not prepared for the
real world you need struggle you need to
start we should be polite to each other
and do our best tonight what what kind
of struggle does this mother seem bro
like what what struggle did this guy
experience I need to understand
but you know what that doesn't mean I'm
gonna tiptoe and pretend I believe [__]
that I don't because of your feelings
this lady has never been polite in her
life okay I'm just gonna keep a buck 50.
okay
you're like one of the most polite
people that I know it's like kind of
annoying sometimes because you're so
polite when you shouldn't be as polite I
mean I definitely they're they're you
could make a whole compilation of videos
of me on the internet that prove his
point oh 100 you know like yeah
but the fact of the matter is he has
never seen me operate in a society in in
a room and actually one of my favorite
things to be is hospitable and polite
and make people comfortable he doesn't
know that though you're not invited
Hassan the invite still is down she does
not strike me as the type of person who
is Ever polite do you understand maybe
I'm wrong but you are honestly you don't
really look like they missed like this
they always even with Tate's message
they miss like so many Key Parts like
these guys teach to be an a gentleman
when you go out tip tip the bound tip
the um tip the bouncer tip the guy that
comes over to your table I know that's
why I like it so much because you taught
me a lot of this stuff but be even more
of a gentleman than what they say if
anything these people are even snarky
right feel like they're always talking
look at this whole video is him making
comments that aren't even true at least
when I go after you or I'm talking about
stuff around Hassan it's based off of
something I'm seeing or that you're
saying yeah and I'm criticizing that or
giving my perspective but he just makes
stuff up and that's what people watch I
mean
uh the the type of person who has ever
been polite what is this relationship
I bet you know what I guess this is a
fair point though because you do see him
not polite in the videos so maybe that's
maybe well in the shorts especially
because you know if you watch the full
videos you're getting full contacts full
conversations but shorts are meant to be
the the little moments where things are
a little and yeah sometimes I get angry
in these videos damn straight I do we're
living in a clown world and I'm not
supposed to feel anything okay Hassan
yeah
and a woman is apparently
and is deciding to date their oppressor
what
it's just like both both like these guys
we already know suck but like Tick Tock
is so [__] annoying it's like yeah
let her cook
ing [__] well Real Talk dog that's
Savage she's a Savage yeah she's so
savagely [__] her pants dude God damn
I'm not gonna lie that makes me cringe I
hate saying like that's Savage like that
is cringy
damn bro we haven't got the right to
vote 100
it's good though you know I like looking
back on myself and recognizing that I
don't say that stuff anymore when I see
growth see less hair you know it's nice
it's good it's that's I've said this
last two videos now like every single
time that I look back at myself from a
few months if I don't look at that
person like a lower version of myself
that I'm doing something wrong that's
that's on this planet who we're not able
to legally vote for the leadership in
this country
for them okay not many like maybe this
mom but like not
that's a wild thing to stay dude are
there
I feel like there's like a handful you
know what I mean there's like maybe
don't even get me started voting like a
[__]
wait what she said I dress like a [__]
bro okay she might have tourettes or
something actually because she's
she called her a [__] what about you
what do you mean why are you calling her
a [__] like she's literally dressed I
said she's dressed like a [__] so get
it clear and the woman in that video was
saying because because this this I stand
by she's like I dress like this for all
the women who fought for me to dress
like this like no Susan B Anthony fought
for your right to vote not to dress up
not to dress like a bimbo and then
complain because in this same video she
was complaining about getting cat called
please I think that one clip has gotten
like close to 50 million to 100.
probably doesn't even know who Susan B
Anthony this girl probably gets
recognized everywhere she goes this poor
Street interview and she became
Collegiate famous
normally what the [__] there's no place
of employment I am
's object every
every day of my life and I'm going
to she works at Hooters that's what you
said I didn't even hear that yeah
because
that's where you work when you're
treated or a strip joint when you're
treated like a sex object everything you
provide some value in a non-sexual way
then that's where your value would be in
the in the office I mean this girl is
just full of herself you're the best
marketer there then that's what they're
gonna be picking your brain for not just
for your your your titties man so stupid
well she loved that one she was like
that was such a funny joke uh but he was
like yeah he thought he thought it was
mid you know what I mean right she works
at Hooters right ooh burn that not
[__] happened
completely safe I'm gonna keep on
fighting for that
yeah I'm so glad that I don't have a
daughter what I'm so glad I don't have a
daughter I think Society is glad you
don't have a daughter what is it what
like Nimrod what bro she pulled out
Nimrod yo if you know or if you use
Nimrod maybe you are 60 he's like
that's valid roasting you for saying
nimrod's funny you know what the thing
is though you look like a nimrod yeah I
actually the more he talks the more I
think he is a nimrod yeah Hassan isn't
Nimrod if he should look it up I don't
even know if it's in the Urban
Dictionary I don't think it might be too
old for that you were a little tipsy
that video eh oh that one yeah near
lexicon you are too old to be on Tick
Tock okay the real Jordan uh nacho
division the real Andrew Tate Lane is
actually the guy who not These Guys
these guys are all fake it's the one
who's like always like yeah I'm skinny
but I have a Lamborghini you think your
girl's gonna want you in your shitty car
or me and my Lamborghini you know that's
the one I wanna that's the one I want to
watch is it this guy yeah that guy's
cringy
um interesting
well I I mean the only valid point he
brought up was that you said Nimrod yeah
maybe you are you're 60 for that one you
know what I don't care
so I said a word from my generation oh
yeah like that's completely invalidates
me give me a break all right well that
was fun
um I really wish though that he had some
more interesting insults because he's
really not a worthy opponent at all can
we get some better insult videos to
react to because that wasn't even
challenging yeah I know at least
critique my points I've said some dumb
[__] man like this
so have I I mean I look back over that
you know we've been doing this now for
like eight months and I look back and
there are times when I look and I'm like
yeah that was mean of me or like I wish
I had said that with more grace or being
a better Christian and all the things
that matter to me but that doesn't mean
that his you know whatever whatever but
all right I'm I'm done with this thank
you so much for watching got a bunch of
crazy content coming up Hassan follow me
on Twitter it'll be fun let's talk there
yep and follow me on Instagram I added
all these videos so I'd really
appreciate it I post some cool pictures
sometimes
let's go all right Alex is awesome peace
guys do that pop up the socials menu
come on
[Music]